like mama tell you all about aspirin did
you know that aspirin may help treat
cancer as well as headaches pains gone
so tensions got it's not the only drug
being used to treat an illness that it
wasn't originally intended for but for
some people using old drugs for new
treatments or repurposing can be the
difference between life and death I
still can't find the appropriate words
to describe how horrible it is to have
to tell your own parents that you'll be
dead before them
Melanie Kennedy mother of two young boys
was diagnosed with breast cancer in 2013
it soon spread to her liver she was
given five years to live if you have an
incurable cancer you want to explore
every option nobody wants to leave their
children early and nobody wants to die
young determined to see her children
grow up she began to search for
experimental treatments to help combat
the disease I did a lot of research into
what else was out there because I wanted
to outlive the five years
I looked into quite a few different
options which is how I find out about
repurposed drugs through a private
health clinic
Melanie began a course of treatment
using repurposed drugs while continuing
conventional chemotherapy with the NHS
the clinic recommended she take an
antibiotic called doxycycline metformin
usually used to treat type 2 diabetes a
statin or cholesterol-lowering drug and
the bender saw a worming agent all these
drugs were designed for other purposes
but may have anti-cancer properties in
simple terms repurposing drugs is taking
an existing drug that has been licensed
for a particular therapeutic indication
or a medical condition and seeking to
use it in a different clinical setting a
very good example is that of aspirin
which actually was initially used as a
painkiller when it was first licensed
nowadays we predominantly use it as a
blood thinner but actually there are
clinical trials in progress looking at
its role in an anti-cancer setting so
why aren't more drugs repurposed when a
new drug is brought to market it is
protected by a patent giving the company
that developed it exclusive rights to
sell it this stops copycat drugs being
sold by competitors allowing the
developer to make a profit but many
existing drugs that could be repurposed
are no longer covered by patents so
companies have less incentive to pay the
costs of testing them for new conditions
and there's another stumbling block
doctors are reluctant to prescribe a
drug to treat an illness that it wasn't
designed for we're very loathe to use
medications outside of the particular
reasons that they're licensed for use
and that's because if there are any
issues when patients then take those
drugs the doctor is ultimately
responsible to make sure Melanie isn't
having problems with the experimental
drugs
she must have regular check-ups hi Mel
lovely to see you wanna just give me a
little bit of an overview how have
things been since we we lost Bochy
I've had another scam after a two-year
course of chemotherapy along with
repurposed drugs her scans are showing
no new evidence of disease when I got
the news that my never was cleared I
wouldn't believe him
I made him turn the computer monitor and
then I read it for myself
doctors can't say with certainty that
her dramatic improvement was caused by
the repurposed drugs for that the trial
she's part of must be completed but
there's a lot of clinical evidence to
suggest that there's a huge untapped
medicine-cabinet of generic drugs that
could help treat cancer and many other
conditions including motor neuron
disease and schizophrenia there are many
benefits of repurposing medications I
suppose that the main one is in terms of
both time and money most new medications
cost over two billion dollars to bring
through the whole clinical trial process
and actually license them for use in
clinical practice that takes a long time
and is expensive for drug companies and
for the NHS
drug repurposing is cheaper than
developing new medicines because the
drug has already been tested for safety
which itself is hugely expensive
[Music]
Melanie believes this trial for saved
her life
but four more trials like this to take
place governments will need to change
the incentives pharmaceutical companies
and solve the patent problem
[Music]